this asset was of extreme importance to
me
this was actually an outtake from the
end of the jack reacher movie but since
werner herzog had dressed up like an
ex-imperial commander for that shoe for
some reason
john favreau decided to use it in this
show these previously on segments at the
beginning of each episode are getting so
long that at some point they're going to
be 40
of the actual show wait this is a star
wars property
did you get the wire out sure this is
[ __ ] adorable but show spends far too
much time on this gag
when we absolutely know baby yoda has no
chance of fixing this issue
not only does baby yo to survive this he
comes out completely unscathed
you know i think we need to visit some
friends for repairs of course you do
this [ __ ] series has more side quests
than red dead redemption 2.
[Music]
generic random species doing villainy
things so we can reintroduce cara dune
to everyone is generic and random
also how has the armorers layer not been
raided before now or why hasn't marshall
haywire confiscated all the mandalorian
bounty there's apparently a mint down
there
also also how the ever loving is this
ferret
weasel slash possum still alive down
here the raid on this layer happened at
least
weeks if not months ago so this poor
bastard should have already starved to
death before it was threatened by these
ass faces
deus ex caronica
[Music]
bringing a knife to a blaster fight this
goofball keeps shooting at the body of
his friend
instead of aiming anywhere else where he
could actually injure martial angel dust
i just want to point out that she had a
lethal weapon the entire time but just
wanted to wrestle to the point of nearly
dying which is dumb
oh great it's a remake of that racist
bruce willis movie from 1998 just what i
expected as a detour on the way to get
yodes back to his jedi brethren
did manu even call ahead to tell them he
was coming or did they just sense a
disturbance in the force or
some bullsh wow they've been gone long
enough for grief's beard to go
completely gray
or it is just for men's supply runout
looks like someone could use some
repairs
i just realized mando is like the kid
who's been at college for the past two
months and comes home with all the dirty
laundry he needs his mom to do for him
i'll get my best people on it and
luckily they happen to be sitting
right over there one of them's an
imperial spy but let me tell you he's so
good at fixing power converters that
it's worth the risk
was that a hint of romance between these
two which makes me wonder do
mandalorians have sex it's not like
they're jedi and can't distract
themselves
as long as he keeps his helmet on and
protection on his other helmet i think
he should be dtf
we're going you don't want to take a
child trust me yeah but he doesn't know
mando is going to help them storm the
base so why dump the kids so early
unless it's only to mine some laughs out
of the macaroon theft
also manu allows this even though the
child has been in a ton of dangerous
situations in this series
well he may even be able to help like
he's done several times already
and there just happens to be one empty
desk for the child to sit at
also this tiny town has this many kids
that are roughly the same age to fill
the class and
none of them are aliens
[Music]
this little dude gets exactly what he
deserves for eating macaroons in class
the c3 teacher unit really needs to get
control of its student population
stealing also kids but over on this side
is the problem
it's an old imperial base and this never
came up in conversation between mando
and his other mandolins during the
entire first season
mando i just want them off my planet but
how do destroying the base guarantee
that
if anything it might make the fallen
empire target their sights even more on
navarro
looks like they're not even really
bothering grief and company in the town
based on this and the events from the
marshall these towns don't seem to know
who their enemy is and who's just a
nuisance they should learn to live with
also wendy didn't give grief the
clearance to call him mando anyway
that's like someone calling me ronnie
and i did not consent to that carlos
the whole base is powered by a reactor
having an understandable conversation in
a normal voice while speeding down the
ravine in a convertible
also how do they know this does this
mean they've scouted this before and if
so why didn't they do something about it
then
sure mando helped swing things a bit in
their favor but surely there's one or
two people in town that could be just as
helpful
also also i have to ask again did they
know amanda was coming
because what if he didn't this seems
more like a set-aside adventure in case
mando came to visit
not something all that important kind of
like if your friends came to visit you
for christmas and you took them to those
lights or whatever holiday touristy
nonsense happens in your town you would
never go there on your own but if you
have visitors it's all of a sudden
something you have to do
empty base huh um they did say there was
a skeleton crew and so far this ain't
that many guards so cool your jetpack
massaholion
i'm totally sure this overhead shot of
kara's dunes adds something to the story
it's a mint trexler marauder i would say
marauder shadowing here just as a joke
but this is such obvious foreshadowing
that they might as well have literally
said
look it's our eventual escape vehicle
from this predicament and for that
obviousness this show gets an extra
three cents
oh man if they screw up this heating
core the bull rock is gonna be
pissed me yes you okay i guess i
understand why they forced the mithril
to drive them out here just as extra
punishment but why are they trusting him
to complete a very serious mission how
do they know he knows what to do
aren't these heroes used to doing stuff
themselves
inside jokes maybe in the fan fiction
that i'm currently working on but i
don't think disney plus is gonna allow
that stuff on one of their flagship
properties
how long do we have ten minutes give or
take a few side quests within this side
quest and honestly that's really a
ridiculous estimate considering i've
never done this before anyway i've been
meaning to ask you about your social
media comments
also running down a corridor in a star
wars property cliche after this whole
jeans guy mistake john favreau made all
of them dressed as stormtroopers
even the grip set designers and catering
staff which sucks
have you ever tried to plate a dozen
veggie burritos and pita chips for a
cast with all that armor on
guillermo del toro's the mandalorian i
don't like this
i prefer my peep shows to be much more
animated it's like they're not even
trying to activate my lightsaber
i highly doubt we'll find a donor with a
higher m count though motherflipping
midichlorians
motherflipping midichlorians meta
[ __ ] mother chlorians
at some point i really do need to have
someone explain how this armor works
all right baby girl ah the star wars
universe where everyone can operate any
vehicle by pushing a few buttons and
engaging in positive self-talk
i know we always make fun of the
stormtroopers being terrible with guns
but why are these two even hanging
around at this point they won't be able
to take out the marauder with two guns
and there's no one else in their general
area
no one will know they're lying if they
tell their superiors they were knocked
out or something
so this one out live another day try
papayas mad max fiery road
why wouldn't these have already taken
off why didn't they start with these
yeah we did it this stillweed celebrates
so prematurely that i have expect
marshall dune to tell him it's all right
happens to a lot of guys
what is going on right there you want to
come back here and try this be my guest
having a conversation while under attack
we're almost down
great let's bring the three heavily
armed tie fighters directly into our
peaceful village full of civilians
holy balls not only was mando able to
get the child board his ship and get in
perfect position for this attack his
heavily damaged ship was fixed in no
time
i'm sorry there's only so much
preciousness i could take before i have
to remove a sin
i did enjoy this episode but there are
so many beats that you can see coming a
mile away like this little spit-up joke
then i have to ding it
it's my job this is the way also how is
he still chomping away on those
macaroons we've seen this thing take
down an entire frog in just a few
seconds
a little bit of food should have been
devoured hours ago along with a silver
sleeve
says here you're from alderaan did you
lose anyone you know when the entire
planet exploded a few years ago
any casualties to relations or was the
family on vacation in flosston paradise
what do you have for me that device has
been planted as you requested so did
they just have this guy planted on
navarro just on the off chance manda
would come to have his ship repaired
stretching your manpower pretty thin if
you're sticking spies on every possible
location he would visit and you're
hoping you have put them in the right
position
the tracking beacon has been installed
on the razor crest doesn't it seem like
tracking beacons are only installed when
it's super convenient in this universe
if there are so many of those things why
not just use them all the time
stacy did you put
in my lunch there's this proud moment in
every content creator's life when their
creative offspring head out on their own
channel adventures and don't need papa
cinema sins anymore well
that don't you forget we're all started
and get your ass back over to cinemasins
before dark
damn kids
[Music]
that's right no now that's the button
that will kill everyone
show me the red wire red wire blue wire
black is usually
[Music]
you son of a [ __ ] i'll get my best
people on it
we have top men working on it right now
who top
men i can't be happy here knowing that
there's
people out there who have nothing
what would you have wakanda do about it
all right out here watched empire and
jedi last week and ever since we've been
trying to do the jedi mind trick
attention earthlings take me to your
dealer
[Applause]
they fly now
but let me assure you this my presence
will be
ornamental you will find me a respectful
quiet passive observer
foreign